there's no ball ready had no more simple
yet oh hey everybody so we get a whole
bunch of new spider-man venom
spider-verse stuff to talk about I know
everyone's asking about agents of shield
because there's a blade rumor there's
also stuff about blade in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so Marvel's really
hardcore characters are all over the
place so we'll start with a venom stuff
then I'll talk about blade then I'll
talk about agents of shield there's also
an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that's
going on right now that I'll mention at
the end of the video so if you guys
didn't know for a long time the carnage
character has been rumored for the venom
movie as sort of the big bad of that
movie because how do you make venom seem
like a good dude you put a bunch of
really crazy symbiotes in the movie so
when people said lethal protector was
the storyline that would serve as the
basis for the venom movie it made a
little more sense but carnage is not a
part of that comic book storyline he is
a part of the Planet of the symbiotes
storyline which is sort of the other
basis for the movie that people have
been talking about so when everyone
heard that Riz Ahmed was cast for the
venom movie they remember him being all
crazy during rogue one so the like maybe
he's going to be the Cletus character of
the venom movie he'll become carnage
he'll be the big bad but here's the
thing he was spotted on set and he was
quoted as being dr. Drake who is a
really key figure from the lethal
protector comic book storyline he's the
leader of The Life Foundation they're
the people that are responsible for
creating all these different versions of
the symbiote that go crazy that venom
then has to take down think of him as a
more polished version of the Ajax
character from the Deadpool movie
somebody who meddles with science and
creates mutant monstrosity but in the
case of the Sony spider-verse
it's just going to be spider-man
symbiotes please don't make the
supersuit green
or animated I'll be interested to see if
they also used the Life Foundation to
explain the creation of Morbius because
they're making a Morbius the living
vampire movie so just open up a tab in
chrome for blade Morbius possible
crossover but the thing about Riz Ahmed
character is that he might wind up being
the big bad of this movie but also being
one of the symbiotes at the same time
just because he's doctor Drake doesn't
mean that they won't Bend Cannon and
give him one of the symbiotes but during
the lethal protector storyline there
were five different symbiotes but they
might decrease that number a little bit
just for the sake of simplicity in the
movie like they might just have him go
after a couple different versions of the
symbiote or even just one maybe that
will be their carnage you may have
forgotten about it but the 90s
spider-man cartoon actually did a
version of the carnage origin story that
was very planet of the symbiotes
something's ringing in my ears
and landed right near here let's see
what it is and like watch something what
are you doing so that might be how the
light foundation and Riz Ahmed character
get their hands on a symbiote because
the only other way to get those
symbiotes is for the Venom symbiote
itself to have the children that it has
in the comics and that feels kind of
weird for the movie they might play it a
little more straight where it's just
another version of the symbiote that
crashes to earth that they then turn
into other symbiotes you may have also
heard that Woody Harrelson just joined
the film we don't know who he's playing
he could just be some normal hardcore
dude like if you saw the final Planet of
the Apes film he plays this really
extreme military guy he could be doing
something like that in the venom movie
or even better he could wind up being
one of the evil symbiotes I don't know
he feels kind of big for a cletus kasady
character but as long as he plays it
crazy enough I think it'll be fine I
think they just want him because he's a
big name and he feels like a big enough
physically big enough dude to take on
Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock character
because they want the villains to feel
like a big threat and Tom Hardy is
already a really intimidating person you
merely adopted the dark I was born in it
so win related spider-verse stuff there
been a lot of rumors about spider-gwen
coming to agents of shield along with
the blade character two completely
separate rumors the blade rumor is just
because one of the people that works at
Marvel was tweeting about agents of
shield and she used a blade hashtag
talking about stuff that's coming up so
people are like does that mean that
blade is coming to the show that would
be weird they did ghostwriter so they
have done hardcore characters like that
before
but here's the thing Wesley Snipes will
not shut up about the fact that there is
only one blade it's him he's probably
just hyping himself up I think when we
see blade again in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
they'll just recast the character with a
younger actor but because the MCU has
not done vampires yet you can't do blade
yet so I feel like what the problem
do is try and cross him over with the
Morbius the living vampire movie that
Sony's doing within their spider-verse
so it sounds a little complicated but
Sony has a live-action spider-verse
with like their really hardcore r-rated
characters then they have the animated
spider-verse
which is Miles Morales so you probably
saw the trailer video for that I'll link
it at the end of this but as for dove
Cameron spider-gwen on agents of shield
people know that she's coming on the
show she posted this funny
behind-the-scenes video being very
mysterious about who she was playing hey
guys so I know I've been promising you
some announcements for a while and I'm
so excited because I finally get to tell
you about one that I've been waiting to
tell you forever the reason why people
think she might be playing spider-gwen
is because she's the actress face of the
spider-gwen character there have a
couple animated shows where she voices
the character there's another brand new
show called Marvel's secret warriors
that she's doing with quake from agents
of shield so people are like okay lots
of spider-gwen stuff happening at Marvel
maybe she's also doing that on agents of
shield but it still feels like we're
years away from seeing a live-action
version of a spider family character on
one of the normal Network TV shows it
feels like they would save that for
their Disney streaming service but we
can follow up on that when she gets
stars on the show it's not gonna be too
long before she debuts so we'll find out
pretty soon same thing goes for the
blade character so if you hear people
talking about blade or spider-gwen on
agents of shield and you go you know
what that does not sound like a thing
that sounds like they would never be
able to use those characters you are
probably correct and from the looks of
the TV show like they're airing episodes
in a really weird schedule so it seems
like ABC is trying to burn episodes of
the show off I don't expect it to get
another season but you never know so
what will happen is is when it comes
back in January I'll do a couple Easter
egg videos for this season but I do feel
like this will be the final season of
agents of shield because it was
confirmed that they had planned to
cancel it after last season but Disney
forced them to keep it on the schedule
so ABC is like you know what you're
gonna force us to keep the TV show that
we don't want we're just gonna burn
episodes off Friday night
the same time we put in humans that
probably got cancelled - although we
haven't got confirmation about that so
if we get any official confirmation on
anything or any updates I'll just add it
to videos whenever it's relevant but let
me know in the comments if you have any
special Marvel TV videos that you guys
want me to do but as of right now no TV
characters are supposed to appear during
infinity war that's usually the question
I get defenders agents of shield none of
those people are supposed to be an
infinity war but if you're finding me
for the first time there's a whole bunch
of that that's getting ready to drop so
be sure to subscribe to get it I'm even
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway you
can actually click on this video to
learn more about that and you can click
here for that spider-verse
trailer with Miles Morales thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]